a olga se le pidió que encontrara cuando
es que fx igual a x2 a la cuarta tiene
puntos de inflexión esta es su solución
y al ver su solución nos preguntan si el
trabajo de olga es correcto y si no cuál
es su error entonces pausa en el vídeo y
vean si pueden resolverlo ustedes solos
ok
primero vamos a ver qué fue lo que hizo
aquí ella saca la primera derivada si
aplicamos la regla de la cadena nos
queda 4 por x menos 2 al cubo por la
derivada de x menos 2 que es 1 así que
esto es correcto y después si sacamos la
derivada de esto nos queda 3 por 4 que
es 12 por x menos 2 al cuadrado por la
derivada de x menos 2 que es 1 y eso es
exactamente lo que ella hizo 12 por x
menos 2 al cuadrado eso es correcto
entonces el primer paso de olga está
bien ahora veamos el paso 2
de la segunda derivada igualada a cero
es x igual a 2 y eso se ve bien porque
la segunda derivada es 12 por x menos 2
al cuadrado y vamos a suponer que eso es
igual a cero ahora esto solamente es
verdadero cuando x es igual a dos así
que el paso 2 también es correcto y en
el paso 3
olga dice que f tiene un punto de
inflexión en x igual a 2
vamos a ver ella está basándose en el
hecho de que la segunda derivada es
igual a cero cuando x es igual a 2
entonces está basándose en el hecho de
que fbi prima de 2 es igual a 0 pero yo
tengo un problema con esto porque si la
segunda derivada es cero cuando x es
igual a todos entonces el número dos es
un buen candidato para que hagamos la
revisión pero no podemos simplemente
decir que tenemos un punto de inflexión
aquí porque recuerden que un punto de
inflexión es cuando pasamos de una
función que
con cava hacia arriba a una cóncava
hacia abajo o de una que es cóncava
hacia abajo a una cóncava hacia arriba y
hablando en el lenguaje de la segunda
derivada esto significa que la segunda
derivada cambia de signos conforme
pasamos por debajo de equis igualados y
por encima de equis igualados pero hay
que comprobar eso porque no siempre es
el caso vamos a corroborar lo pensemos
en algunos intervalos intervalos y vamos
a pensar en el intervalo que va de menos
infinito a 2 y en el intervalo que va de
2 a infinito y si queremos podemos
definir algunos valores de prueba de
prueba y también podemos pensar en el
signo de la segunda derivada y sabiendo
eso podemos conocer la concavidad de f
ok entonces analicemos lo que ocurre
primero vamos a tomar un valor de prueba
vamos a suponer uno que se encuentra
dentro de este intervalo y tres que se
encuentra en este intervalo ok así que
podemos decir que uno menos dos al
cuadrado es igual a vamos a ver
menos uno al cuadrado es igual a uno y
después eso por 12 entonces esto será
positivo y si ahora probamos con 33
menos 2 al cuadrado es 1 y eso por 12
bueno también es positivo por lo tanto
aquí la función es cóncava hacia arriba
al menos con estos valores porque el
signo de la segunda derivada es positivo
en los dos lados de x igualados y tal
vez me digan bueno tal vez solo
necesitamos encontrar valores más
cercanos
pero si inspeccionamos la segunda
derivada podemos ver que esto nunca será
negativo de hecho para cualquier otro
valor diferente de x igual a 2
este valor aún cuando x2 fuera negativo
todo esto se eleva al cuadrado por lo
que todo esto termina siendo positivo y
luego lo multiplicamos por un valor
positivo así que para cualquier valor
diferente de x igual a 2 el signo de la
segunda derivada es positivo lo que
significa que es cóncava hacia arriba
entonces realmente no tenemos un punto
de inflexión en x igualados porque no
hay un cambio de signo conforme pasamos
de valores menores a x igualados y
valores mayores a x igual a 2
la segunda derivada no cambia de signo
así que esto es incorrecto no hay un
punto de inflexión cuando x es igual a 2
porque la segunda derivada no cambia de
signo al pasar por x 2 y eso significa
que nuestra concavidad no